I've been asked to talk to you today about an essay that I wrote for the New York times
last year which went under a rather dramatic heading.
It was called "Why you will marry the wrong person"
and perhaps we could just begin
- we're among friends- by just asking how many of you in the room do feel on balance
that you have married the wrong person ? I mean, we're among friends
I mean yeah
A lady there- couple of people there- five, ten? I'd say 30 people in the room and and so we always have to triple that
So there's a pretty hefty majority but I'm here to give counsel and to give consolation for this situation
You know there's a lot of anger around our love lives privately held
But a lot of us go around feeling quite enraged, angry privately about the way that our love lives have gone
My task today is to turn that anger into sadness
If we if we manage to turn rage into grief we will have made psychological progress and
This is that the task today
What lies behind rage very often is an unusual quality because we tend to think that very angry people are
sort of dark and pessimistic characters absolutely not. Scratch the surface of any
regularly angry person and you will find a wild optimist. It is in fact hope that drives rage
Think of a person who screams every time they can't find their house keys or every time they get stuck in traffic
These unfortunate characters are evincing a curious
but reckless faith in a world in which keys never go astray, the roads are mysteriously traffic free
It is hope that is turbocharging their rage. So if we're to get a little bit less sad
And as a little less angry about our love lives, we will have to diminish some of our hopes
It's very hard to diminish hope around love because there are vast industries designed to inflate our expectations of love
There was wonderful quote from the German Philosopher, Theodor adorno
Who in the 1960s said that the most dangerous man in America
was Walt Disney and the reason for his attack on Walt was because he believed that Walt was the prime agent of hope and
therefore of rage and therefore of bitterness
And he thought that it was the task of philosophy to let us down
gently, which is what I'm going to be doing today. So remember the theme of the talk why you will marry the wrong person
There are a number of reasons
why this is going to happen to you, or has maybe already in the privacy of your heart happen to you.
I should say that it's not that bad and the reason is that all of us
Will not manage to find the right person
But we will probably all of us manage to find a good enough person
So and that's success
as you will come to see. One of the reasons why we're not going to be able to pull this one off as
Successfully as we might have hoped at the early the outset of our
Upper teenage perd when we were contemplating love is that we are very strange. I'm very strange, and you're very strange
You don't let on and you know we're not going to do anything very dangerous, but we are basically psyChologically quite strange
we don't normally know very much about this strangeness it takes us a long time before we're really on top of
The way in which we are hard to live with. Is there anyone in this room think that. They're quite easy to live with
On balance yeah, oh my goodness. Okay? I don't want to be rude, but please come and see me afterwards. I know
I know that you're not easy to live with and the reason is that you're a homo sapiens and therefore you are not easy to
live with no one is. And
But there's a there's a wall of silence that surrounds us from a deeper acquaintance with what is actually so difficult about us
Our friends don't want to tell us why would they bother? They just want to pleasant evening out.
they're not.. our friends know more about us and more about our flaws probably after a ten minutes acquaintance a
Stranger will know more about your flaws then you might learn over 40 years of life on the planet
Our capacity to intuit what is wrong with us is very weak. Our parents don't tell us very much
Why would they? they love us too much, they know they can see of course I mean they followed us from the crib
They know what's wrong with us
They're not going to tell us because they they just want to be sweet. Our ex-lovers a vital source of knowledge
They know. Absolutely. They know
But you remember that speech that they gave it was it was moving at the time when they said that they wanted a little more
Space and were attracted to travel and were interested in the culture of Southeast Asia, nonsense!
They thought lots of things are wrong with you
But they weren't going to bother to tell you they were just off out of there
Why would they bother? So there's knowledge that is out there is not in you.
It's out there, but it's not in you and so therefore we progress through the world with a very
Low sense of what is actually wrong with us
Not least all of us addicts almost all of us are addicts not injecting heroin as such but addicts in the sense we need to
Redefine what addiction is I like to define addiction not in terms of the substance you're taking in other words. I'm heroin addict
I'm a cocaine addict no
Addiction is basically any pattern of behavior whereby you cannot stand to be with yourself and certain of the more uncomfortable
thoughts and more importantly emotions that come from being on your own and
So therefore you can be addicted to almost anything so long as it keeps you away from yourself
so it was it keeps you away from tricky self-knowledge and most of us are addicts and
thanks to all sorts of technologies and
Distractions Etc we can have a good life where we will almost certainly be guaranteed not to spend any time with ourselves.
Except maybe for certain kind of airlines that still don't have the gadgets to distract us, but otherwise you can be guaranteed
You don't have to talk to yourself
And this is a disaster for your capacity to have a relationship with another person because until you know yourself, you can't properly relate to
another person
One of the reasons why love is so tricky for us is that it requires us to do something
We really don't want to do which is to approach another human being and say I need you. I wouldn't really survive without you
I'm vulnerable before you and
There's a very strong impulse in all of us to be strong and to be well defended and not to reveal our
vulnerability to another person psycho
Psychologists talk of two patterns of response that tend to crop up in people whenever there's a danger of needing to be extremely vulnerable
Dangerously vulnerable and exposed to another person the first response is to get what what?
psychologists call
anxiously attached
Attachment theory some of you may know
So when you are anxiously attached to somebody rather than saying I need you,
I depend on you you start to get very procedural you say you're ten minutes late
Or I think the bin bags need to be taken out or you start to get strict when actually what you want to do is
To ask a very poignant question do you still care about me, but we don't dare to ask that question
So instead we get nasty we get stiff
We get procedural the other thing the other pattern of behavior which pSychologists have identified and it tends to apply to people who?
Are in this room in other words a types very outgoing types strivers you become in relationships?
Tell me if I'm wrong you become what is known as avoidant
Which means that when you when you need someone it's precisely at that moment you pretend you don't
When you feel most vulnerable you say, I'm quite busy at the moment. I'm fine. Thanks
I'm well busy today in other words
you don't reveal the need for another person which sets them off into a chain of wandering whether
You are to be trusted, and there's been a cycle of low trust
So we get into these patterns of not daring to do the thing that we really need to do which is to say even though
I'm a growing person maybe I've got a beard maybe I've been alive for a long time. I'm 6 foot 2 ETC
I'm actually a small child inside, and I need you like a small child would need its parent
this is so humbling that most of us refuse to make that step and therefore refuse the challenge of
Of love um in short
we don't know very much how to love we and it sounds very odd because
Actually somebody said you look all of us probably in this room would probably need to go to a school of love
What? A school of love? love is just an instinct! No.
It's not. It's a skill and it's a skill that needs to be learned
And it's a skill that our society refuses to consider as a skill
We are meant to always just follow our feelings if you keep following your feelings you will almost certainly make a big mistake
In your life. What is love? Ultimately love I believe is something personal
there's a distinction between
Loving and being loved. We all start off in life by knowing a lot about being loved being loved is the fun bit
That's when somebody brings you something on a tray and ask you how your day at school went etcetera
And we grow up thinking that that is what's going to happen in an adult relationship. We can be forgiven for that
It's an understandable mistake
But it's a very tragic mistake
And it leads us not to pay attention to the other side of the equation
Which is to love and what does it really mean to love - love ultimately is to have the willingness to
Interpret someone's on the surface not very appealing behavior in order to find more Benevolent reasons
why it may be unfolding in other words to love someone is to apply charity and generosity of
Interpretation most of us are in dire need of love because actually we need to be we need to have some slack cut for us
Because our behavior is often so tricky that if we don't do this we wouldn't get through any kind of relationship
But we're not used to thinking that that is the core of what love is. Core of what love is is the willingness to
Interpret another's behavior
What we tend to be very bad at is
Recognizing that anyone that we can love is going to be a perplexing mixture of the good and the bad there's a wonderful
psychoanalyst called Melanie Klein who was active in the 50s and 60s recently from Vienna active in North London studying how children learned about relationships
from the parental
Situation and she came up with a very fascinating
Analysis, she argued that when children are small very small
They don't really realize that a parent is one character
they actually do what she calls split a parent into a good parent and a bad parent and so this is when a
Baby is in a really an infant stage
so what you do is you split into the good mother or and the bad mother and
It takes a long long time melanie Klien thought it might be until you're four
Until you actually realize that the good and the bad mother are one person and you become ambivalent in other words
You become able to hate someone and really go off them and at the same time also love them
And you're able not to run away from that situation
You're able to say
I love someone and hate them and that's okay and melanie Klein thought
This is an immense psychological achievement when we can no longer merely divide people into absolutely Brilliant perfect
What marvelous and hateful, let-me-down,
Disappointed me everyone who we love is going to disappoint as we start off with idealization and we end up often with denigration
The person goes from being absolutely marvelous to be absolutely terrible
Maturity is the ability to see that there are no heroes or sinners
really among human beings that all of us and this wonderfully perplexing mixture of the good and the bad and
Adulthood true psychological Maturity and may need to be 65 before it hits you
I'm not there yet is the capacity to realize that anyone that you love is going to be this mixture of
The good and the bad, so love is not just admiration for strength
it is also tolerance for weakness and recognition of ambivalence and
the reason why we're going to
Probably make some real mistakes when we choose our love partners some of you in this room have made some stunning mistakes now
Why is this? The reason is that we've been told that the way to find a good partner is to follow your instinct
Right follow your heart. That's the Mantra, and so we're all the time reminded that if we stop
Reasoning analyzing other people in this room who think that you can think too much about your emotions
And that sort of you people get yeah, you can think too much a few people okay?
You can't think too much you can only ever think badly
But there's no such thing as thinking too much about emotions
but the problem is we live in a romantic culture that privileges impulse and when it comes to love something tricky occurs because
You don't have to be a paid-up believer in psychotherapy of psychoanalysis to realize that the way
We love as adults sits on top of our early childhood experiences and in early childhood the way that we learnt about love
Was not just via experiences of tenderness and kindness and generosity
The love that we will have tasted as children will also be bound up with
experiences of being let down being humiliated maybe being with a parent who
Treated us very harshly who scolded us who made us feel small in some way in other words
Quite a lot about our early experiences of love a bound up with various kinds of suffering
Now something quite bad happens when we start to go out into the adult world and start to choose loved partners
We think we're out to find partners who will make us happy
but we're not. We're out to find partners who will feel familiar, and that may be a very different thing because
Familiarity may be bound up with particular kinds of torture
This explains why sometimes people will say to us. There's a wonderful person. You should go and date them
they're good-looking that charming there are all sorts of things and we go out with them when we date them and
We do recognize that
They're really wonderful and amazing but we have to confess to our partners
To our friends that actually we found this person- often we struggle with the vocabulary- we say
Maybe not that exciting or maybe not sexy or a bit boring..
But really what we mean is that we've detected in this really quite accomplished person
someone who will not be able to make a
Suffer in the way that we need to suffer in order to feel that love is real, and that's why we reject them
So we are not merely on a quest to be happy
We are on a quest to suffer in ways that feel familiar and this
Radically undermines our capacity to find a good partner
Here's another reason. Why we're going to come unstuck in the field of love
We tend to believe that the more a lover is right for us the less we're going to have to explain
About who we are how we feel what upsets us what we want we believe rather as a young child believes of its parent
That a true lover will guess what is in our minds one of the great errors that human beings make it's permanently to feel
That other people know what's in their minds without us having said what's in our minds. It's very cumbersome to use words
It's such a bore and when it comes to love we have this deep desire that we'll simply be understood wordlessly
It's touching it's a beautiful romantic idea
But it also leads to a catastrophic outbreak of sulking and what is sulking? Sulking is an interesting phenomenon
we don't just sulk with anyone we sulk with people who we feel should understand us and
yet for some reason had decided not to and
that's why we tend to reserve our sulks for people who we love and who we think love us and
They tell us something you know they
Unwittingly will trigger a negative reaction in us and we'll sulk and they'll say what's wrong with you darling
And we'll say nothing and they'll say but come on. You're upset and we'll go no. I'm not
I'm absolutely fine, and it's not true, and we'll go upstairs and we'll shut the door, and we won't tell them
What's wrong with us, and then they'll knock at the door and that's it. Please just tell me and we'll say no
Because we want them to read our souls
Because we expect that a true lover can understand what we feel and who we are without us speaking
This is a catastrophe for our capacity to form lasting relationships. If you do not explain
You can never be understood. The route to a good marriage and to good love is the ability to become a good teacher
Now teaching sounds like a narrow profession those guys in tweed jackets and fusty with it with a chalkboard Etc
I'm not talking about that kind of teaching. All of us whatever our job aspirations, whatever it is
We do have to
Become teachers. Now, teaching is merely the word that we give to the skill of getting an idea from one head into another
in a way that it's likely to be accepted and
Most of us are appalling teachers most of us teach when we're tired when we're frightened. What are we frightened of? We're frightened
We've married an idiot and because we're so frightened. We start screaming at them
You've got to understand and the thing is that unfortunately by the time you've started to humiliate the person you want to understand something less
And over you will never get anyone to understand what you want them to understand so long as you make them feel
Small in order to teach well you need to be relaxed you need to accept that maybe your partner won't understand
And also you need a culture within a couple
That two people are going to need to teach each other and therefore also learn from one another and this brings me to the next
reason why you're going to have a very unhappy relationship probably and that is because you probably believe
That when somebody tries to tell you something about yourself that's a little ticklish and a little uncomfortable. They are attacking you
They're not. They're trying to make you into a better person
And we don't tend to believe that this has a role in love. We tend to believe that true
Love means accepting the whole of us. It doesn't no one should accept the whole of us
We're appalling really one of the whole of you accepted
No
That's not love that
the full display of our
Characters the full articulation of who we are should not be something that we do in front of anyone that we care about
So what we need to do
Is is to accept that the other person is going to want to educate us and that it isn't a criticism Criticism is
Merely the wrong word that we apply to a much noble idea
Which is to try and make us into better versions of ourselves, but we tend to reject this idea
very strongly
Is there any hope? Of course there's hope! Look I mentioned the word good enough?
It's a phrase taken from a wonderful English pSYchoanalyst called Donald, Winnicott
He had a lot of parents who would come to him and say things like I'm so worried
I'm not a good parent my child has this problem, or that problem ETC, and he came up with a wonderful phrase
He said you are most likely to be a good enough parent and it's a relief from our otherwise punishing
Perfectionism the good thing is that none of us are perfect and therefore we don't need
Perfection and the demand for Perfection will lead you to only one thing
Loneliness. You cannot have perfection and company. To be in company with another person is to be negotiating
imperfection every day
Incompatibility- we are all incompatible, but it is the work of love to make us
graciously accommodate each other and ourselves to each other's incompatibilities and
Therefore compatibility is an achievement of love. It. Isn't what you need from the outset of course you're not going to be totally compatible
That's not the point it is through love that you gradually accept the need
To be compatible um we probably can't change our types? Right, so all of us a problem
Many of us are have got types who are going to cause us real problems. They may be too distant there may be arrogant
They're going to torture us in some way now friends
Casually say to us chuck them get out the relationship ETC, right?
No, I don't you know we're realists here at Google, and I'm giving you realistic advice
You're not going to manage to change your type
Let's get that for granted what you can do, and this is a big achievement is to change how you
characteristically respond to your tricky type
Most of us have formed the way that we respond to tricky types in early childhood
so we had a distant parent with mattres and a distant lover when we were very young we responded to that distant parent by
Attention-seeking we rattled and banged an our adult we rattle and bang in our own way, and we think that's going to help
it doesn't it create a
Cycle that's going to be a vicious cycle
It's not going to get us anywhere it is open to us at any time to have a more mature
response to the
challenges that the types of people were attracted to are going to pose for us and that is an immense step forward and Immense achievement
Um the other thing we should do is recognize the nobility of compromise
What are the most shameful things to ever have to admit is to say this is my partner.
I've compromised in choosing them. I've compromised. Oh, why have you compromised? Well? I'm not that attractive myself. I've got lots of problems
I'm a bit nutty frankly. I couldn't pull anyone better, but they're very nice okay now you would think loser
It's not true compromise is Noble. We compromise in every area of life
There's no reason why we shouldn't compromise in our love life. Maybe we're sticking around for the children
Good it was a "Oh!, they're only sticking around for the children." That's a wonderful reason to stick around
Why else are you Gonna stick around?
So let's look a bit more benevolently at the art of compromise
It's a massive achievement in love I'm going to end with with a quote from one of my favorite philosophers
Danish nineteenth-century very Gloomy philosopher called Kierkegaard and Kierkegaard in his book either all had a wonderful
Outburst what he basically said of course you're going to marry the wrong person and make the wrong decisions in a whole row of
Areas and the reason you're going to do this is that you're human therefore. Do not berate yourself for doing
What humans do this is what he says marry, and you will regret it
Don't marry you will also regret it marry, or don't marry you will get it either way laughs of the world's foolishness
You'll regret it weep over it you'll regret that to laugh at the world's foolishness or weep over it
You will regret both hang yourself. You will regret it
Don't hang yourself you will regret that to hang yourself or don't hang yourself
You'll regret it either way whether you hang yourself or don't hang yourself you will regret both this gentleman is the essence of all
Philosophy, thank you very much
we publish new
Thought-Provoking films every week be sure to subscribe to our channel and take a look at more of what we have to offer
At the link on your screen now